in this video you're gonna learn how to
solve triangles involving the ambiguous
case the side-side-angle case and
specifically I'm going to show you a
problem where there's two triangles
possible and how to solve those
triangles but first I want to show you
how do you even identify if there's one
triangle to triangle or even no triangle
possible when they're giving you
side-side-angle
and so the first thing I want to show
you is when you have an obtuse triangle
the main thing you want to pay attention
to is like see if they give you this
side they give you this side and they
give you this angle right here okay and
what you want to do is you want to make
sure that the side that's across from
that angle when it's obtuse is the
longest side if this side here is longer
than this side here then what happens is
if you were to really draw it accurately
it would look something like this where
it doesn't actually form a triangle and
there's no triangle possible now when
you do the law of sines down here or
what you'll find is that you actually
get an error message on your calculator
when there's no triangle possible but
just so that you can save yourself a
snap if this is longer and this is
shorter and it's across from the up to
sing like that there's no triangle now
what happens if this is the longest side
across from the obtuse angle well then
you just have one triangle okay so
that's pretty straightforward now what
happens when you have like an angle over
here that's not I'm gonna use this a
lowercase a meaning it's an acute angle
it's not obtuse and they give you this
side here that's adjacent to the acute
angle and the side that's across from
the acute angle well what you're gonna
want to do is you're gonna want to drop
a perpendicular they call this the
altitude or the height okay to this
other side like this and what we're
gonna do is we're gonna analyze whether
there's one true or no triangles now if
this side here that's across from the
acute angle if this side is longer than
this side adjacent and there's only
gonna be one triangle possible and the
way to look at it is like this we don't
know what this angle is up here right so
we can think of this as like a hinge if
we were to like take this whole side
here and like rotate it if I was to
rotate this it would actually extend
past this this side right here and so
there's really no triangle possible now
what happens if this side right here is
in between the length of the altitude in
the
the adjacent side well then what happens
that's more like this triangle down here
what we can actually do is we can rotate
it like so so we actually get two
possible triangles so you can kind of
think of this as like the radius of a
circle and you're rotating that it's
going to intersect this side here
opposite in two different locations so
you can have two triangles possible
that's we're gonna look at in this video
what happens if this side right here is
exactly the same length as this altitude
well if it's exactly the same length
what that means is that this is actually
going to be a right triangle
okay so there's only one triangle
possible and then what happens if let's
see what happens if this side right here
is actually shorter than the altitude so
let's I was to draw that more accurately
like this see even if we try to rotate
it what happens is it's not going to be
long enough to reach that opposite side
and then there's no triangle possible of
course when you do the law of sines
you're gonna give me an error message
but just so you know that's what's
happening is you actually can't form a
triangle in that case so let's go ahead
and look at this one so what we're gonna
do first is we're going to drop that
altitude like so I'm gonna call that H
and if we cover up this side of the
triangle we have a right triangle here
we can use there a regular sine cosine
tangent to solve for the height the sine
of 30 equals the opposite side over the
hypotenuse so let's just write that over
here of sine 30 equals opposite over
hypotenuse now if I multiply both sides
by 12 that cancels and then I know the
sine of 30 is 1/2 or you can do this on
your calculator times 12 is 6 okay so we
know now that the height equals 6
but notice how this side across from the
acute angle the 12 is in between the
altitude and the side adjacent which
means that we can rotate it like so okay
so I'm just taking that and turning it
so we could get a triangle looks like
this let's go ahead and redraw it it
looks something like that or it would
just look like the original triangle
something like that so let's go and
write down what we have here we have 30
degrees angle a we have B we have C we
have 20 we have 12 same thing over here
a 30 degrees 2012 and this is C and this
is B and that's it okay so now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna start off
by solving for this angle right here
angle
and so the reason I'm doing that is
because we need to do a lot of signs
you've got the sine of the angle over
the side opposite sign of the angle over
the side opposite the ones that cross
from each other they form like a pair
and we can make a proportion so let's go
ahead and do that we've got sine of 30
degrees over 12 equals sine of angle C
over inside side opposite which is 20 if
I multiply both sides by 20
we've got sine of C equals this quantity
and I'm going to take the sine inverse
to solve for angle C so let's go to the
calculator make sure you're in degree
mode and we've got check my work on this
20 times the sine of 30 divided by 12
and I'm going to take the sine inverse
of that answer and I'm getting fifty six
point four I'm just going to round to
the nearest tenth so this is fifty six
point four now here's where students get
a little bit confused about the second
triangle you see how I rotated this like
this that means that this side right
here is 12 as well and so what do you
have when you have a triangle it has two
sides that are congruent well that's an
isosceles triangle and what do we know
about the base angles of an isosceles
triangle well they're congruent so if
this is fifty six point four this is
fifty six point four but you see this
angle right here next to it and see how
these form a linear pair that means that
this angle is 180 minus fifty six point
four which is how much it's a hundred
and twenty three point six right so when
I go down to this triangle right here
I'm going to put in our hundred and
twenty three point six degrees now what
we have is we have two angles in a
triangle we can solve for the third
angle by adding those up and subtracting
from 180 so let's go ahead and do that
so 30 plus 50 6.4 okay and let's do that
again 30 plus 50 6.4 I'm gonna take away
from 180 so it comes out to ninety three
point six for angle B and over here same
thing we've got 30 plus 120 three point
six take that from 180 and we're getting
twenty six point four degrees okay now
all we have left to do is solve for this
side here across from angle B side B
same thing over here in this triangle
you're gonna want to do two separate law
of sines to solve because the two
triangles are separate so let's go do
this one here first we've got a sine of
30 over 12 and I like to go back to the
original numbers if at all possible just
so I don't you know if I made a mistake
here or if I rounded a little bit I
don't want to carry forth that rounding
error
so let's go sine of ninety three point
six all divided by this side here I'll
just call D so let's go ahead and
multiply both let's cross multiply so
we've got a V times the sine of 30
equals 12 times the sine of ninety three
point six divide both sides by sine of
30 okay keep that balanced and then now
what I'm going to do is solve for B so
we've got 12 sine of ninety three point
six divided by sine of 30 and so that
comes out to about 23 well it's actually
to about twenty four point zero if we
round to the nearest tenth so that's
twenty four point zero over here in this
triangle same thing we're gonna do sine
of thirty over twelve going back to
those original values equals sine of
twenty six point four over side B again
I'm going to cross multiply just to get
rid of the fractions here using the
means extremes property as it's called
and then let's divide both sides by sine
of thirty because want to get B by
itself and let's see what does that come
out to so twelve sine of twenty six
point four check my work on this divided
by sine of thirty I'm getting ten point
seven so that's this over here is ten
point seven and you can see you saw both
triangles we had two measures for angle
C we had two measures for angle B we had
two lengths for side B and you got it if
you want to see more about the law of
cosines and how to work with the law of
cosines follow me over to that video
right there where we dive into some more
examples